YouTube Heroes
*YouTube Heroes ad plays*
The latest update to Youtube
We all laughed when it came
We all thought "HA!" another stupid
idea from YouTube
It won't matter
It won't matter for shit
But we were wrong
*music plays*
While you all laughed,
guess who signed up for YouTube Heroes...
That's right
This guy
And since I have 49 million subscribers
It means I qualify
for the highest rank
Oh yeah!
YouTube let's me to combat clickbait,
edit anyone's titles on YouTube,
and you know who cares more
about clickbait than anyone?
*dramatic music plays*
Oh you guessed it again!
This guy!
So we're gonna censor everyone else's
videos
and put what the real title is
on their shitty clickbait videos
together, today :)
It's gonna be a fun time!
Leave a like at any point during
you enjoying this video 👍
If you feel like, "HA!
Yeah that's a like 👍 for it!"
*weird mumbling*
Let's begin!
Buzzfeed!
Uff
Ugh
'Girls Answer If Size Matters'
Video: Oh, god it does.
Video: No it does not.
That's a straight up lie,
you looked down,
that means you're lying.
Watch that again.
Video: No it does not.
🎵 She's a liar, she's a liar 🎵
🎵 She's a motherfuckin' liar 🎵
Video: I think length isn't as important,
Video: but I think girth is more
Just admit it!
Video: If a guy is very well endowed,
he doesn't try as hard.
JUST SAY IT!
Video: It's really how you work it :)
Way to dodge the quest-
OKAY, how about this!
'Girls Don't Answer If Size Matters They Avoid The Fucken Question And Straight Up Lie About It'
I have a butthole
and you think I can't tell if this comes in *pinky*
or if this comes in *fist*?
Are you gon-
Are you serious right now?
I mean I haven't done it
I haven't tried it,
but if I wanted to try it-
Listen, I don't even have to try it to know it.
Shut up!
I-I haven't
No.
Maybe the pinky finger one,
just to see what it was-
SHUT UP!
What was this video about?
Clickbait.
Right!
Next one!
'Should You Live With Your Crush?'
Well we got a flat ass here on the left!
Flat ass...
on the left...
but...
apparently you'll still click.
I mean not that there's anything wrong
with flat ass.
Don't get me wrong, I don't want to
offend anyone 😭
I don't want people to feel bad if they watch
my videos
especially not about their physical appearance
BUT JESUS CHRIST!
It's like a pancake!
'Should You Get Butt Implants?'
That's a better title!
You're welcome!
See I'm helping you now.
*laughs*
Also- also a thing that I noticed which I think is really funny
Is that
Someone- some-
Some lil' shmuck at BuzzFeed
made this thumbnail.
and there was no text
there was no text on
there was just these image
and they *laughs*
the person thought,
"You know what?
It needs-
It needs to say fucked there,
but we need to censor-
we need to censor it cuz' we're Buck-
we're BuzzFeed and a bunch- a bunch of cucks.
So let's add 'fucked'
and let's add a little-
let's add a little brushy thing.
Yeah, that!
That's it!"
It's like, "Ah!
Ah! What a great thumbnail!"
But you know it misses?
FUCKED
No, no, no, no, no, no, nonono
There ya go!
Oh.
No.
No. No. No.
Oh!
OH!
Oh.
Oh, shit dawg!
Oh man.
Oh.
Oh, yes :)
BuzzFeed
Now what was this video about, I forgot?
I keep- I keep forget, alright... 🙁
'YOGA CHALLENGE WITH MY GIRLFRIEND!'
I swear I've seen this somewhere else
Oh yeah, Chubbs tweeted.
Okay.
Here's the title:
'Dry Humping My Girlfriend For Views In Front Of My Audience Of Ten Year Olds'
Now that's-
that's pretty accurate, at least.
Wait.
Is this Roman Atwood?
My job as a YouTube Hero
this is too much effort.
Okay. We'll just change them all.
'Emotionally Manipulating My Audience Of 8 Yr Olds'
'I'M MOVING TO ENGLAND'
Really?
Wait, what? I'm going to England for my book tour
Oh. Okay. So...
'I'M A FUCKEN LIAR!'
There you go :)
*reading* Getting GTA 6 early. You won't believe this.
This YouTuber got GTA 6 early. You won't believe what happens.
Getting GTA 6 early...
Man I didn't know GTA community was so fucking cancer.
Sorry.
*reading* YouTube should delete my channel.
'Top 5 YouTubers Who ALMOST DIED!'
*mumbles* Roman Atwood, Lance Stewart, ComedyShortsGamer
Oh! 'Top 5 YouTubers Who SHOULD have Died!'
That's not funny Poods.
Hey.
'I'm Quitting YouTube Forever'
Well, I'm not gonna click on this video.
I refu- you know what, I refuse
But I'm gonna bet my um my left nut
that Leafy is not quitting
because they never quit.
YouTubers don't quit,
and for a very simple reason:
AdSense
It's a beautiful thing.
Okay.
That's the title.
'AdSense Is A Beautiful Thing. I Will Never Quit YouTube As Long As It Keeps Giving Me That Sweet Juice I Wish It Would Pay A Little More BUT HEY, That Doesn't Mean I'm Gonna Quit'
You know what.
I'll eat my left testicle-
if Leafy quits,
and never uploads a video.
I'm serious.
100%
(of what) I'm saying right now
Is not a call out.
I will eat my left testicle.
'I QUIT (for now)'
Oh, oh I-
*laughs*
I got this one.
"Boo Hoo. My Life is Sooooooo Hard Being A Millionaire. (Thanks To YouTube)
Done.
Aaaaaaaaaah eh now done
Oh BOI
Being a YouTube Hero
sure is a lot of work.
I didn't realize
how fuckin' shit
the clickbait *laughs* on YouTube is
until I asked-
I asked people to send me the worst, cuz'
it's uh
YouTube 2016, man. It's been a good year for clickbait.
This has been me fixing
clickbait titles.
You are welcome.
It's been my pleasure.
And if you ya, if ya smiled anytime at this video
go ahead and leave a like 👍
and I'll see you bros in the next video.
And as always
Leave a like 👍
*outro music plays*